THE UNIT STES HEADS INTO
THE 20 PREDEL ECTION
TOHT ON CNN.
>> N THTUMP'S LATEST
HOURS OF EACH OTHER  THE
FORMRENTMP POSTING
TODAIN PART QUOTE, SHAWN FAIN
AS APO MDESTRUCTION
UTO WORKERS IN THE
INDUSTRY IN THITTATES
ALL AUOR SHOULD ALL
CAPS VOTE FOR TRUMP JUST HOURS
EARLIER, TRUMP BASHED FAIN BY
SAYING THIS HE'S A REAL
ALL-CAPS STIFF. WHO ISELLING
INA, GET RID OF ISE ANDOT
FJT TRUMP ADMITTING
HIS INITIAL ATTACK BSE
OF THIINTEIEW WE'RE FAIN
DID NOT HOLD BACK AND
EXPLAINING WHY HE HAS CHOSEN TO
ENDORSE BIDEN INSTEAD OF TRUMP
>> DOND UMP HAS A HISTORY
OF SERVINGSEND SNDING
FOE BILLIONAIRE CLASS. AND
THAT'S RAO EVERYTHING
THAT WORKING CLASS PPLE STAND
FOR.
>>HAWNAIN IS OUTFRONT NOW,
SOHAWN DONALD TRUMP SAYSOU
ARA WEAPON OF MASS
DESTCTION THATOU A
SAID ALL THOSE TNGS TODAY.
RESPOND TO THA   E
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
, YOKNOW, FIRST OFF,HE
WEAPON OF MASS DTRUCON
AINSTHE TOMOTIVE INDUSTRY
HAS EN TORCORPATE
GREEYOU KNOW, TH WRUMP
TRUMP ALWAYSESORTS TO NAME
VERY CLEAR. D O'T WAARE
TALK ABOUT THE TRUTH.
KNOW, HE TALBOHAT
FACTS ARE WHAT WE ALLL LIES
HEANTSO MAKE THIS ELECON
ABOUT ANHIBUT REAL ISSUES
DONALD TRU. N'T  E O
WHAT DONALD TRUMP SA ABOUT
I D'T CAREHAT HE THINKS
ABOUT LET ME I CARABOUT
FAS. AND THE FACTS ARE VERY
CLEAR THE RGE MAJORITY OF
ERICS. THE WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
THE BILLIONAIRDDIEAND THE
THE, F THE WEALTHY. AND, YOU
KNOW, LOOK19I RE
THISHE OTHER DAY FROM TH
ECONOMIC PY INITUTE FROM
1979 TO 20, THP 0.1% OF
344%. E BOTTOM 90%NCREED
32%. SO THISS ANCONO THATRUMP DA
HE WANTS.  DOE'T GIVE A
ABT WOING CLASS PEOPLEAN
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALLBO
AIGHT, SO ONE THING TT
HES CONNECTING WITH IN S
WAY IS A SENTINTT AT
LEHAS GRN WITHIN
UNNIZED HOUSEHOLDS, RIGHT?
AND TH IS A SHIFT OVER TIME
ADMITTED THIS SELFXIAOU'VE
ENU  T ARE RANK AND
TRDOES APPEAL TO. R HARRYHAT
N WAS LOOKING AT SOME
NUMBERS AND EN I'M REFERRING
TO AS A SHOVOR TIME AN
OVERALL UNION MEMBER VOTE
TOWARDS THE REPUBLICAN, RIGH
STILTI PLUS DEMOCRAT. BUT
E'S BEEN A SHIFT, RIGHT,
POINTS PLU DEMOCRAT 1992 62
THAT HAD BEEN CUT IN HALF TO
. BY0, IT WAS DOWN TO
22% NTAGE FOR DEMOCRATS
HOW DO YOUNKHAT E OSIO
THAT MANY OF YOUMBERDO
IT'S EN A MASR PLANNED  IS IS
BY TLIONRE CLASS IN A
CORPORATE CLAS IN, TY,
ER L40, 50
>> YEARSOUR LIVES, HAV
PLAYHEATESGAME. THEY
ALWAYS PLAY D THAT'S DIVIDE
AND CONQUER.HEVIHE
ES OR SINGLE ISSUE A
AND THINGS GET WSE FOR US.
WE VE TO DO AS ORGANIZED
LABOR,E HA TO LEAD THE
FIGHT AND WE HAVTO LEAD THE
DIALOGUEH FAS. AND
TH'S WHY ARE CONTCTCAMPGN WAS SE
SO SCESSL WITH THE BIG
REE AT'S WHY OF
AMERICANS SIDEWITHS HAT
FIGHT. BECAUSE WE  FOCED
TO WORKING CLA PPLE.ES,
BETTER WAGESETIRENT,
HEALTH CARE FOEVERYBY AN
GETTING OUR  BAC Y
KNOW, I'SHAMUL THROUGH ALL
OF THIS WORKING CLASPELE
WORKING HARDERND LGER THAN
DAYS A W 1HOURS A DAY, WORKING R
SCRAPINGO GET . THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE ONTHATHE ES.
BILLIONAE CLASS VES. AND IT
DOESN'T RK F WORKING CLASS
PELE. AND I K  WE
FOCUS ON THE CORE ES
TTERT WORKCL
OPLEILL SEE A DIFFERENCE IN
I KNOW TYOD NOYOU HAD,
LED T MEETING WITH TMP,
BUT THE TEAMSTERS N OT
IN. THEY'VE 1
MILLION MBWRITSSIV
WEEKRE'S EVENT' MEETING WITH UNH
IN WHAT? AND SAY
EAR  M, HE MET WITH
D OF THE TEAMSRS U A
MAR-A-LAGO. OUE ANY
FEEL FOR HOWHIS  G BE?
TEAMSTERS UNION, DO YOU THK
ENDOEMENT? TTING THEIR
>> LOOK, I'VE TKED TO SEAN
'BRIEN. I RESPECT SEAN
'IEE'S A HE'S OD
LEADND LK, TY'VE HAD
DONE GREAT THINGAND I'M NOT
GOING TO TO EV SPEAK FOR
CAN SPEAK FOR ROM OM OUR
IN THE FACTS WEEN.ND SEE
IT'S REALLY CLEAR FOR US,
IT'A  CLEAR PICTURE W
YOU PUT THE O CANDIDATES
SIY-SI, I AN, YOU GO
BAO THE ECOMIC RECESSION
JOE BIDEN OOD WI THE
ICANORKER DOLD TRUMP,
WAS WRONG TH TIG THREE  T
PATHORWARD. YOU KN, YOGOTO TRUM
2019, LOSTASSELY PLANT
IN OHIO WAS SLATEDCL
UMP AME THE LOCAL
PRESIDENT, TD PE DO'T
SELLOUR USES AND DID
ING IN 2019 WHEN GM ON
STRIKE. AT DD TRUMP,
TRESINT SAY,
DN'T SAY ANYTHINGHEN'T
DO ANYTHING IN 2023 JOE BIDEN
WH WE WE ON RIKEHE CAME
OUT AND STWIHE WKERS.
IN ILLINOIWAS ED PLAET
S WRITTEN OFF FODEADE
BIWOITH  TO NOT JUST
GET ONE PLANT, WE GOT THAT
IENTO BE BUILT THE AND
SAVEHE COMMUNITY. SO T'S
STCONTST AND THESE